Traductor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
¿Alguna vez has notado algo nadando
en tu campo visual?
Se asemeja a un gusano pequeño
o una burbuja transparente,
y cada vez que
intentas enfocarlos, desaparecen,
para reaparecer tan pronto
como alejas la mirada.
¡Pero no vayas a enjuagarte los ojos!
Lo que ves es un fenómeno común
conocido como cuerpos flotantes.
El nombre científico de estos cuerpos
es "Muscae volitantes",
que en latín significa
"moscas volantes"
y fiel a su nombre,
pueden ser un poco molestos.
Pero no se trata ni de gusanos
ni de objetos externos reales en absoluto.
Más bien,
existen dentro del globo ocular.
Las moscas volantes parecen vivas,
porque se mueven y cambian de forma,
pero no lo están.
Los cuerpos flotantes son objetos mínimos
que proyectan sombras en la retina,
el tejido sensible a la luz
en la parte posterior del ojo.
Pueden ser trozos de tejido,
glóbulos rojos,
o agregados de proteínas.
Y como están suspendidos
en el humor vítreo,
el líquido gelatinoso
que llena el interior del ojo,
flotan a la deriva
con el movimiento de los ojos,
y parecen rebotar un poco
cuando el ojo se detiene.
Las moscas volantes apenas se distinguen
la mayor parte del tiempo.
Llegan a ser más visibles
cuanto más cerca están de la retina,
al igual que al acercar más la mano
a una mesa con una lámpara de techo
resultará una sombra
definida más claramente.
Y son particularmente visibles
cuando miras una
superficie brillante uniforme,
como una pantalla de
computadora en blanco,
la nieve,
o un cielo despejado,
donde la consistencia del fondo
hace que sean más fáciles de distinguir.
Cuanto más brillante es la luz,
más se contrae tu pupila.
Esto tiene un efecto similar a cambiar
una gran instalación de luz difusa
por una sola bombilla,
lo que también hace que
la sombra parezca más nítida.
Hay otro fenómeno visual
que se parece a las moscas voladores
pero que de hecho no está relacionado.
Si ves pequeños puntos
de luz que resaltan
cuando miras a un cielo azul brillante,
has experimentado lo que se conoce como
fenómeno entóptico del campo azul.
En cierto modo, esto es lo contrario
a ver objetos flotantes.
Aquí, no ves sombras
sino pequeños puntos brillantes
en movimiento dejando luz en tu retina.
Los puntos brillantes los causan
los glóbulos blancos
moviéndose a través de los capilares
frente a la superficie de la retina.
Estos leucocitos pueden ser tan grandes
que pueden casi llenar un capilar
formando un espacio de plasma
que se abre ante ellos.
Como el espacio
en los glóbulos blancos
es más transparente a la luz azul
que los glóbulos rojos que normalmente
están presentes en los capilares,
vemos un punto en movimiento
de luz allí donde esto sucede,
siguiendo los caminos de tus capilares
y moviéndose al ritmo de tu pulso.
En condiciones ideales de visualización,
incluso puedes ver lo que parece ser
una cola oscura siguiendo el punto.
Esto son los glóbulos rojos que
se han agrupados detrás de los leucocitos.
Algunos museos de ciencia tienen una
exposición con una pantalla de luz azul,
que permite ver este fenómeno del campo
azul más claramente que lo normal.
Aunque los ojos de todos
experimentan este tipo de efectos,
el número y el tipo varían mucho.
En el caso de las moscas volantes,
a menudo pasan desapercibidas
porque el cerebro aprende a ignorarlas.
Sin embargo, si son muy numerosas
o son grandes objetos flotantes
que interfieren con la visión
pueden ser signo de una afección más grave
que requiere tratamiento médico inmediato.
Pero la mayoría de las veces
los fenómenos entópticos,
como las moscas volantes o
el fenómeno entóptico del campo azul,
son solo un recordatorio de que
lo que creemos ver
depende tanto de
nuestra biología y nuestra mente
como de nuestro mundo externo.